[Musique]
c'est quoi l'inspiration profonde qui
nous amener à faire cet album welcome
back est d'abord on voulait laisser
liberté de création à aux artistes puis
après on samia aussi à réfléchir
ensemble c'est quoi le limbourg tu sais
quoi qu'on voulait communiquer et
artistiquement maccarthyste comment
est-ce qu'on se place face au monde dans
lequel on vit
donc depuis 2010 8 onces ami a réfléchi
travaillent ensemble puis avait toujours
une santé aux gens ça très très
importante une sens de un sentiment
qu'il fallait faire quelque chose où on
allait trop vite
c'est un vieux nice d'où la montagne si
vivendi gagne
[Musique]
à
bastide
cet allemand voulait communiquer cette
urgence à quai en santé enfin les êtres
humains en tant qu'artiste cette urgence
à agir d un peu ralentir faire changer
un peu la direction de s en aller
et puis voilà cet album fait partie de
mise en scène aussi sur la crise a mis à
mettre toute cette questionnement assure
formes de spectacles dans lesquels on
parlait souvent on était dans un bateau
qui analysent rencontré une tempête en
solo solo soli pescado solo morrison sur
le sol us et donc on attend le moment de
présenter à cette et spectacle est pour
l'instant justement c'est que la jeune
et très fier de l'avoir ça c'est notre
album welcome back qui communique c'est
aux gens ces sentiments de il nous faut
nous répond c'est en tant que société
puis de repenser notre place dans ce
monde qu'un partage avec les autres
êtres vivante qui est son ami
[Musique]